[Musique]
nucléaire en Polynésie en quête de
vérité documentaire exclusifs réalisés
par Emmanuel Amara car après l'Algérie
c'est donc en Polynésie à plus de 15000
km de Paris que ce sont déroulés
jusqu'en 1996 l'essentiel des essais
nucléaires français et plus d'un quart
de siècle après ce territoire ultramarin
paye en Corse vous venez de le voir les
conséquences sanitaires
environnementales et politiques de ces
essais menés à l'époque dans le plus
grand secret quelles leçons pouvons-nous
tirer des conditions dans lesquelles ce
sont effectués ces essais les
réparations de l'État sont-elles
aujourd'hui à la hauteur des attentes
des victimes nous allons maintenant
chercher les réponses à ces questions
auprès de nos invités présents sur ce
plateau de débat doc avec vous tout
d'abord pour commencer Thomas status
bien sûr bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
auteur avec l'enseignant chercheur
Sébastien Philippe de ce livre toxique
enquête sur les essais nucléaires en
Polynésie c'est un ouvrage
au presse universitaire de France et
disclose
car c'était d'abord une enquête destinée
au journal disclose c'est enquête que
vous avez réalisé avec Sébastien
Philippe avec un certain nombre de
révélations sur lesquels on va revenir
bien sûr dans un instant avec Benoît
Pélopidas bienvenue à vous vous êtes
enseignant chercheur fondateur du
programme d'études des savoirs
nucléaires au sein du Centre des
relations internationales de Sciences Po
de séries bien entendu et vous êtes
l'auteur entre autres de ce livre
intitulé repenser les choix nucléaires
et publiés au presse de Sciences Po et
puis enfin avec nous Jean-Louis camusa
bienvenue à vous vous êtes le président
de l'Avent c'est l'association des
vétérans des essais nucléaires et comme
d'autres vous êtes aussi un ancien
appelé qui au sein de la Marine
nationale ont participé à des essais
nucléaires en Polynésie vous étiez sur
place en 1969 et 1970 vous avez insister
à 6 essais nucléaires atmosphériques à
l'époque cela fait quoi d'assister un
essai nucléaire quel souvenir vous en
gardez le souvenir je serais tenté de
dire c'est beau un même même si c'est
peut-être dramatique après pour les sur
les ondes de santé mais quand on voit
l'évolution du champignon quand on voit
l'environnement qu'on voit c'est c'est
vraiment joli et vous étiez où pour
assister à ces essais sur un navire
comme on voit pour un certain nombre de
vos collègues dans ce film alors moi
personnellement en tant que marin oui
j'étais à bord d'un bâtiment base qui
quittait bien sûr la tôle de murora pour
aller à un point x donc quelques
kilomètres du point zéro pour voir
l'évolution de
la bombe atomique quelques kilomètres
20 18 20 ça dépendait
dans de la puissance des tirs dans ce
film quel précaution à l'époque la
Marine nationale
vous a-t-elle demandé de prendre pour
assister à ses essais moi je serais
tenté de dire aucune la seule consigne
que l'on avait c'était qu'au dans les
derniers instants du compte à rebours on
devait se tourner le dos au flash et la
tête dans l'avant-bras
après on nous demandait de on se
retournait on se faisait prendre en
photo et on voyait le développement de
de la bombe quoi alors pas d'équipement
spécial qu'un équipement ni lunettes ni
enfin moi nous personnellement son nom
de bateau il y avait aucune précaution
et ça a été le cas pour les 6 essais
auquel vous avez assisté où il y a une
évolution non non tous les essais tous
les essais pareil il y a jamais eu de de
mesures de sécurité particulière
qu'est-ce que vous ressentez aujourd'hui
à titre personnel vous pouvez peut-être
parler au nom de tous les adhérents de
votre association est-ce que vous sentez
de l'amertume après coup ou alors est-ce
que vous dites bah c'est le devoir
accompli malgré tout si vous voulez au
début on est on est parti servir notre
pays avant tout puisque c'était l'époque
encore où le service militaire était
obligatoire donc on partait on savait
pas trop où on allait moi j'étais
heureux comme tout je partais pour moi
je partais au Club Med je faisais un
demi tour du monde en bateau donc
c'était donc c'était en gros le Club Med
oui pour tout le monde et arriver sur
site on a commencé à se rendre compte de
ce qui laisse passer parce que on voyait
tout un tas de choses et où on a
réellement pris tous conscience qu'on
assistait à quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est quand on a vu ce
fameux ballon dirigeable jaune se
gonfler au-dessus du lagon et là on nous
a informés qu'il allait avoir une
expansion atomique ce fameux ballon
dirigeable qu'on voit aussi dans ce
documentaire mais vous avez pas tout à
fait répondu à ma question il y a de
l'amertume aujourd'hui oui oui quelque
part oui parce que bah oui parce que si
vous voulez on était tous un petit peu
inconscient on était on était informé de
rien du tout et avec le recul maintenant
et au sein de l'association bon on
s'aperçoit que c'est peut-être
votre lit votre enquête tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert
qui n'avait pas été découvert jusque là
sur ces fameuses essais en Polynésie
française entre 66 et 96 alors cette
enquête qu'on a fait avec disclose avec
le chercheur Sébastien Philippe comme
vous le rappelez qui est chercheur à
l'université de Princeton d'ailleurs on
a vu certaines des modalisations dans le
documentaire université sprintson mais
c'est université de prison et disclos
c'était un travail conjoint et je
voulais le rappeler parce que la
singularité de notre travail c'est
celui-là c'est à dire qu'on a travaillé
un chercheur un journaliste des gens qui
font de la modélisation donc qui
modélisent ces essais ce qu'on a fait
c'est que pendant deux ans on a
décortiqué les données françaises les
documents qui ont été déclassifiés alors
document des classifier on parle des
documents de 2013 c'est la première
volet c'est le premier volet de des
classifications si j'ai bien exactement
à cette époque là en fait des centaines
de documents sont déclassifiés grâce au
travail de la veine et d'autres
associations qui travaillent sur ce
sujet à l'époque
un document c'est des documents
techniques et dedans on trouve tout un
tas de données et de chiffres qui nous
permettent en fait à posteriori de
refaire des calculs et de réestimer la
contamination à la fois des populations
civiles mais aussi des militaires et
nous ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a fait
un travail d'évaluation méticuleux
indépendant qui n'est pas en fait un
récit historique et nous on voulait
aussi proposer un récit à hauteur de
victimes on pense pas aujourd'hui vous
avez estimé l'ensemble des dégâts cons
suscité ces essais nucléaires alors on
peut les quantifier de manière assez
simple ouais sur le plan humain par
exemple on peut les quantifier de
manière assez simple nous ce qu'on a
estimé c'est que pour les 6 essais
nucléaires les plus importants nos
estimations sont entre 2 et à 10 fois
supérieur à la contamination qui
envisageait par l'état français et pour
un exemple qui est assez central qui est
celui de laisser centort en novembre
1974 juillet juillet par
17 juillet 1974 et ça c'est une date que
n'ont pas oublié les les Polynésiens et
là on compte que c'est quasiment 110000
personnes qui ont été touchées par le
nuage qui 42 heures après l'explosion
touche l'île principale de Tahiti et je
voulais juste finir ça c'est la grande
révélation de votre livre et vous dites
110 000 personnes aurait pu être touchés
par les radiations c'est en parle de 110
000 personnes c'est la quasi totalité en
réalité des atolls polynésiens qui
auraient été touché avec ce fameux
essais santor sachant que c'est Atol lui
représente à peu près la la surface de
l'Europe c'est ça c'est pourquoi les
gens se rendent bien compte de 110 000
personnes c'est plus particulièrement en
fait la population de l'île principale
de la Polynésie française où est situé
la ville de papeet qui reprenait où il y
a le plus de population à cette époque
là c'est ça le chiffre de 110 000 est
représentent ça et nous cette histoire
ce qui nous importait je voulais finir
là-dessus c'est de le raconter à hauteur
de victimes c'est à dire en fait de
raconter aussi les gens qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup entendu qui ne sont parfois des
témoins de cette grande machine
militaire qui s'est mis en oeuvre mais
qui sont souvent des oubliés je pense
aux militaires je pense aux ouvriers de
numéro roi et je pense aussi aux
victimes civil polynésienne qui sont
souvent les plus oubliés aussi et celles
pour lequel il est parfois très très
difficile d'obtenir réparation et
d'obtenir une indemnisation de l'État et
donc ce travail là on l'a fait à la fois
avec des recoupements de témoignages
avec exclusifs mais aussi en utilisant
ces données françaises qui n'avaient pas
été exploitées est-ce que l'État
français a confirmé les chiffres que
vous avez avancés dans dans ce livre
j'ai vu que Mario sec qui est là la
secrétaire d'État aux anciens
combattants avait réfuté vos chiffres
vous avez pu en parler avec elle non on
n'a pas parlé avec elle ceci dit les
chiffres correspond qu'on a sorti
correspondent aussi il y a une sorte de
d'accord on va dire d'état de l'art
scientifique sur le sujet et
correspondent à peu près à la fourchette
aussi que donne d'autres scientifiques
qui sont plutôt on va dire des médecins
sur ce sujet précis de la contamination
alors lorsqu'on parle de contamination
parle surtout des essais atmosphériques
est-ce qu'on peut recontextualiser ce
qu'on était les essais
nucléaire français alors d'une part au
Sahara qui n'est pas traitée ne sont pas
traités dans le film que nous venons de
voir il y a eu des essais au Sahara il y
en a eu 17 entre 1960 et 1966 et puis
bien sûr en Polynésie française comment
est-ce qu'on peut recontextualiser ses
essais français des années 60 alors je
vous donne trois éléments de réponse la
première c'est comme vous le disiez la
campagne d'essai atmosphérique française
commence au Sahara en 1960 parce que
pour cette première génération d'État
dotés d'armes nucléaires ont signal la
possession d'armes nucléaire en faisant
un essai donc le premier essai c'est en
février 1960 on passe ensuite en
souterrain et on repart après en
atmosphérique le j'insiste juste sur le
choix de la Polynésie parce que c'est
l'objet du documentaire la discussion de
ce qu'on va appeler le site lointain et
ensuite le centre d'essai du Pacifique
commence dans les années 50 parce que on
anticipe les événements d'Algérie donc
au moment des accords d'Évian il y a une
possibilité de continuer à tester en
Algérie mais pour cinq ans et donc de la
fin des années 50 au début des années 60
on prévoit déjà le transfert vers le ce
qu'on appelle le site lointain un
élément un dernier élément
en écho en fait à ce qu'on voit dans le
documentaire et à l'histoire du club med
que disait que disait mon copain analyse
ça peut donner l'impression que aussi en
métropole il y avait un enthousiasme
totalement partagé pour cette campagne
d'essai et dans les archives ce qu'on
trouve c'est un sondage en fait de
juillet et septembre 1966 après le début
des essais nucléaires en Polynésie ou
51% des Français sont opposés aux essais
nucléaire en Polynésie seulement 31 sont
favorables et 15% sans opinion donc
j'ajoute juste un élément du paysage
qu'on voit pas dans le documentaire la
France a semble-t-il hésiter entre
plusieurs sites pour effectuer ces
essais nucléaires après
l'Algérie et notamment elle avait évoqué
la possibilité de site en métropole dans
l'Hexagone finalement ça a été le choix
de la Polynésie c'est ça justifie
comment selon vous ce choix parce que
justement c'est un choix lointain qui
touche la population d'outre-mer comment
on justifie ce choix alors il y a une il
y a un des choix le plus choix le plus
proche dont on est connaissance ou la
possibilité la plus proche dont on est
connaissance et l'accord il va du coup
être rejeté et on va choisir comme vous
le disiez la Polynésie l'historien
Jean-Marc Regnault qui apparaît dans le
dos absolument à avancer le fait que il
y avait une raison politique qui est de
gestion de la protestation avec un
postulat que en Polynésie justement on
pourrait gérer plus facilement la
contestation des essais par rapport à
une expérience de la protestation qui
avait eu lieu en Algérie on a beaucoup
parlé des des dégâts
occasionnés par les essais
atmosphériques un dégât sanitaire on
reviendra sur les dégâts
environnementaux un peu plus tard parce
que là ça concerne plutôt les essais
souterrains en revanche en préparant ce
dos sier j'ai constaté que les
États-Unis d'une part l'URSS d'autre
part avait stoppé tout essais nucléaire
atmosphérique dès 1963
[Musique]
vendeur de réparation concernant ces
essais alors les les demandes de nos
vétérans si vous voulez c'est bon on a
un chiffre qui est global mais si vous
voulez on beaucoup de nos vétérances se
posent quand même la question de leur
état de santé et à travers notre
association
puisse se rendre compte un petit peu des
dégâts et des fameux cancers reconnus et
peuvent présenter ce qu'on appelle un
dossier de demande d'indemnisation et
prétendent à indemnisation alors c'est
c'est assez simple dès l'instant qu'ils
faisaient partie de la force entre les
années précitées qui sont atteints d'un
des 23 cancers et voilà donc ils sont
dit indemnisables après il y a une
constitution de dossier présentée à
notre avocat et ce dossier est présenté
à la commission d'indemnisation qui
définit un petit peu le le cas de chaque
vétéran le marqueur législatif
concernant la prise en compte évidemment
des demandes des revendications des des
anciens des vétérans des victimes d'une
agence c'est 2010 c'est la fameuse loi
Morin du nom de l'ancien ministre de la
Défense Hervé Morin qui effectivement à
ce moment-là mais en place une procédure
d'indemnisation pour les personnes
atteintes de maladies résultant d'une
exposition au rayonnement des essais
nucléaires réalisés à la fois dans le
Sahara algérien et en Polynésie
française et on crée donc le comité
d'indemnisation des victimes des essais
nucléaires qui s'appelle le Siven et
c'est là qu'effectivement sont déposés
les dossiers les victimes les requêtes
des victimes il y a combien de dossiers
aujourd'hui traités par le civen combien
ont été traités est-ce qu'on peut faire
un bilan là alors en gros si vous voulez
le le dossiers présentés aussi veine de
la veine représente à peu près 800
dossiers bon aujourd'hui on est
peut-être à 5 600
acceptations de dossiers bon beaucoup
euh il y a donc acceptation de dossier
ça veut dire que ce sont des des
personnes qui vont devenir restauration
voilà qui vont obtenir réparation à
savoir que là il y a souvent une enquête
après qui est une enquête un peu plus
poussée avec une expertise médicale bon
il y a certains
dossiers qui sont encore au dans les
tribunaux administratifs donc c'est mes
globalement si vous voulez il y a quand
même une prise de conscience des des
maladies ou des cancers radio ionisants
aux personnes qui ont participé à ces
essais tantôt Sarah quand Polynésie et
c'est vrai que il y a quand même une
écoute il y a une attention qui a été
prise depuis quelques années et encore
plus là depuis l'apparition du livre de
de Thomas où il y a il y a vraiment là
les verrous ont sauté et il y a eu une
prise de conscience des dégâts qu'on
peut occasionner les essais et vous
citiez le chiffre de 23 cancers tout à
l'heure parce que c'est le nombre de
cancers
identifié qui serait dû aux radiations
voilà c'est bien ça au jour
d'aujourd'hui jusqu'à 23 cancers
reconnus liés au rayon ionisant quelles
sont les attentes sur place des victimes
alors là on parle des vétérans pour
l'essentiel enfin il y a évidemment tous
ces polynésiens sur place qui ont vécu
subit ces essais si je peux me permettre
de nuancer le propos de Monsieur camusa
qui a quelqu'un un interlocuteur avec
qui on a beaucoup échangé la veine nous
a beaucoup aidé dans cette enquête et je
leur je les en remercie il y a une
grande différence quand même il faut
rappeler que sur cette histoire de
l'indemnisation des essais nucléaires il
y a quand même plusieurs périodes
d'abord il y a une première période de
début 2010 ou quasiment l'intégralité
des dossiers sont rejetés c'est-à-dire
qu'on crée il y a quand même une
interrogation que nous on apportait dans
ce livre c'est pourquoi donc l'état
français crée un comité d'indemnisation
pour l'indemniser personne puisque la
première année si je me trompera je
crois que c'est quasiment 98% de rejet
et ensuite
les choses se changent modifier au fil
des années et finalement on voit quand
même différents dossiers différentes
situations effectivement les militaires
ont une forte acceptation parce qu'en
fait ils sont en mesure de prouver leur
présence mesure de prouver leur
contamination parce qu'ils avaient des
relevés ils avaient un suivi médical ce
qui n'est absolument pas le cas ni des
sous-traitants puisque en fait l'armée
embauché des entreprises locales des
Polynésiens comme vous le dites ni des
civils qui ont beaucoup plus de mal pour
revenir à votre question sur l'attente
des Polynésiens il faut rappeler une
chose c'est que la Polynésie française
est un territoire français qui est très
distant de la métropole et là-bas c'est
un sujet assez important parce que c'est
un sujet mémorial évidemment un sujet où
on a menti pendant des années à ces
gens-là quoi Candy finalement la
puissance publique je veux dire les
faits et d'ailleurs dans le documentaire
vous citez ce document la coquille où il
est marqué il faudra minimiser les
conséquences qui est un document qui a
été publié par le journaliste Vincent
jovers du Nouvel Observateur il faut
rendre à César ce qu'il y a César c'est
lui qui a la fin des années 90 a été le
premier à publier sur ce sujet là il y a
eu ce mensonge et aussi ça a été une
période de bouleversement pour la
Polynésie française c'était une période
violente il faut se rappeler aussi c'est
l'arrivée de dizaines voire centaines de
milliers de métropolitains dans un
territoire qui est éloignait ça pose des
questions il y a des infrastructures qui
sont construites mais il y a aussi tout
un questionnement qui revient assez
souvent évidemment c'est un sujet qui
est toujours brûlant Polynésie française
et on l'a vu au moment de la publication
de l'enquête qui a eu beaucoup en France
métropolitaine mais aussi en Polynésie
française
[Musique]
document qui prouve qu'on a cherché du
côté en tout cas de de l'armée française
à minimiser les effets de ses effets
dans les suggestions pour la deuxième
campagne il est écrit
il sera peut-être nécessaire de
minimiser les chiffres réels de façon à
ne pas perdre la confiance de la
population qui se rendrait compte que
quelque chose lui a été caché dès le
premier tir
les habitants n'ont alors aucune idée de
ce qu'ils subissent
a été contaminé par la France
les poissons ont tous été empoisonnés
alors Emmanuel Macron c'est en juillet
dernier c'était le 27 juillet dernier à
reconnu que la France avait une dette
vis-à-vis de la Polynésie française à
propos de de ses essais nucléaires
comment à traiter ce sujet
l'armée française sur place pendant ces
essais elle a cherché effectivement
c'est ce que ce document semble dire à
minimiser autant que possible les effets
potentiels comment ça a été géré ça du
côté de l'armée française vis-à-vis de
la population locale l'essence
l'essentiel du point de vue de la
production de connaissances et de se
focaliser non pas sur essayer
d'authentifier l'intention qui préside à
ce qu'on a fait et bien d'observer les
effets de ce que l'armée française a
fait et donc là le documentaire présente
certaines preuves de
et ce que si on met en perspective par
rapport à l'histoire nucléaire globale
ce que ça montre aussi c'est que les
institutions en charge des programmes
nucléaires projettent systématiquement
un grand récit du contrôle ça se
retrouve de manière parallèle aux
États-Unis en France au Royaume-Uni et
c'est pour ça tout à l'heure vous
parliez justement de validation des
dossiers d'indemnisation moi je voulais
faire un détour sur justement qu'est-ce
que c'est que la validation de la
connaissance le documentaire s'appelle
enquête de vérité ce qui est frappant
c'est que dans votre documentaire vous
avez plusieurs types de vérité qui
coexistent vous avez la vérité la vérité
en l'occurrence sur la disait pas au
polynésien et on la disait pas non plus
et vous pouvez en témoigner qui était
présent sur place non mais bien sûr
c'est mais c'est pour ça justement que
je vous disais après une première disons
génération de l'historiographie ou la
vérité qui est privilégiée c'est la
vérité de ceux qui planifient ou donc on
va passer sous silence les ratés les
choses peu contrôler le le pari si vous
voulez de la recherche indépendante
c'est d'ouvrir la place à d'autres voix
et de rendre possible l'évaluation des
effets des essais et c'est pour ça que
le travail de Thomas et de Sébastien
Philippe qui est aussi chercheur associé
à mon programme ce qui est important
c'est leur résultat empirique mais
surtout de mon point de vue le fait
qu'ils ont créé une méthode qui nous
permet de ne pas dépendre des sources
juste disponibles et des modes de calcul
disponibles ils nous permettent de nous
mettre à distance et de revalider
indépendamment des effets et ce qu'il y
a de très forts que Thomas n'a pas dit
c'est que le travail fait pour toxique
il est fait sur la France mais cette
méthode elle est potentiellement
réplicable aux autres essais
atmosphériques des autres puissances
nucléaires il faut bien voir qu'on a eu
plus de 500 essais nucléaires
atmosphérique de par le monde et qu'on a
une connaissance assez limitée de ces
essais dans la plupart des pays autres
et de leurs conséquences absolument et
puisque vous avez à dire sur ce sujet le
fait qu'on ait minimisé évidemment les
conséquences sur place
vous n'avez jamais vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure vous n'avez pas été informé
des risques bien sûr on a aucun moment
on avait aucune information de toute
façon bon les médias de l'époque ne sont
pas n'étaient pas ce qui sont
aujourd'hui donc on n'avait pas une on
avait une information qui était très
minime et la prise de conscience des
vétérans
elle est née du jour où il y a eu la
création de la veine parce que au début
on est tout le monde rentrait dans ses
foyers il y avait peut-être des petits
problèmes de santé mais qui était pas ça
n'a l'air telle personne et quand la
veine ça a été créée en 2001 donc ça
fait 20 ans si vous voulez là il y a une
prise de conscience parce que il y a
d'abord il y a eu de la communication il
y a eu de la médiatisation il y a eu de
l'information et là si vous voulez les
personnels qui ont fréquenté les sites
d'expérimentation ce sont retrouvés un
petit peu avec des méthodologie qui
était annoncée et de là si vous voulez
l'association a grossi avec
l'association murura est atout puisqu'on
est un petit peu les deux associations
liées si vous voulez métropolitaine et
polynes et c'est parti de là où il y a
eu une prise de conscience des maladies
radio induites donc effectivement on a
eu la loi en 2010 la loi dite morale qui
a eu le mérite d'exister que l'on a fait
que l'on fait évoluer principalement sur
l'évolution des pathologies sur voilà et
là il y a une réelle prise de conscience
et la dernière prise de conscience c'est
le livre de Thomas qui a fait vraiment
sauter les verrous avec cette table
ronde
demandée par le président frits le
président polynésien avec le
gouvernement français et là il y a
vraiment eu une prise de conscience du
président de la République qui a dit
textuellement arrêtons de dire que les
essais étaient propres je me dois de
réparer donc ça a été un petit peu le
démarrage et avec tout un tas de de
discours en Polynésie qui sont plutôt
favorables pour l'avancement des
vétérans en l'occurrence c'est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'Emmanuel Macron c'est
différencier de ces prédécesseurs sur ce
dossier qu'il s'est un peu accaparé ce
dossier mémoriel comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure alors moi les Polynésiens
moi je dirais un peu les choses
autrement je dirais que de la part de
l'exécutif il y a eu une obligation de
prendre en charge ce dossier face à la
réponse à la fois de la veine et de la
population polynésienne indéniablement
c'est à dire que quand quand notre livre
est sorti mais notre livre n'a fait que
permettre de réactiver d'une certaine
manière quelque chose qui existait et
d'ailleurs qui s'exprimait déjà en
Polynésie française je veux dire il a
pas fallu attendre toxique pour que les
Polynésiens disent quelque chose sur cet
héritage nucléaire ça il faut quand même
le rappeler c'est pas que nous nous on a
fait une partie du travail on est
journaliste et journalistes et
chercheurs en physique nucléaire on
essaie de faire un peu ce qu'on peut et
puis le documentaire qu'on a vu
contribue aussi à faire avancer le
dossier moi moi je ferais manuel Macron
il s'est saisi du sujet après il y a
beaucoup de points d'interrogation alors
il y a eu des promesses qui ont été fait
évidemment qui sont en fait finalement
l'avenant de ce qui s'est fait
précédemment on promet un petit peu plus
d'argent pour la caisse de sécurité
sociale polynésienne on promet un petit
peu pour pour la recherche sur le cancer
la question fondamentale et qui est
celle qui abordait les cabas des Benoît
je trouve qu'il est assez importantes
c'est cette question du secret du lever
du secret c'est à dire que la ce qui a
été arraché par les associations aussi à
la table ronde c'est la déclassification
de nouveaux documents et la question est
de savoir qu'est-ce qui va sortir de ces
documents et qui les déclassifie en tout
cela elle a été mise en route puisque
c'était en octobre dernier on a élargi
la déclarification des documents alors
évidemment indéniablement s'interroge
comme vous dites quel document et
peut-être que la question c'est qui les
déclassifié c'est à dire que de ce que
l'on en sait du processus où les
associations sont partis prenantes bien
sûr c'est avant tout aussi un processus
qui est validé par l'armée le
commissariat l'énergie atomique donc la
question se pose est-ce qu'on peut être
jugé partie dans une histoire est-ce
qu'on peut faire les essais et décider
comment on produit la connaissance là
dessus votre avis sur ce sujet de la
déclassification des documents c'était
un engagement d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'occasion d'ailleurs de cette table
ronde qui s'est déroulé tout début
juillet de l'année dernière
oui alors
la spécificité de la France il faut la
voir de manière comparative au
Royaume-Uni aux États-Unis on a ce qu'on
appelle un freelome offenformation acte
c'est à dire qui nous perd qui permet de
demander la déclassification de
documents secrets des forces et la
raison pour laquelle j'insiste là-dessus
justement par contraste avec la France
c'est que grâce à ces mécanismes de
classification là on a pu mettre en
cause ou en tout cas montrer les
fissures dans les récits du contrôle
parfait un argument sur lequel je veux
insister parce que avant le travail de
mon équipe il existait pas c'est le fait
que depuis les années 60 on a un nombre
de politiciens de militaires qui disent
dans certains épisodes particuliers on a
échappé à des explosions nucléaires non
désirées par chance et ce discours de la
chance il était trop souvent traité
comme oh c'est un décidable donc on va
faire comme si tout était contrôlé or on
peut montrer que la chance a été
nécessaire mais
de témoignages historique on se rend
compte que à l'époque la question
environnementale est pas du tout quelque
chose qui est pris en compte pas aucun
responsabilité il y a des récits de des
colonies d'oiseaux qui sont morts enfin
je veux dire il faut s'imaginer ce que
c'est une bombe nucléaire une bombe
nucléaire c'est grosso modo le même
fonctionnement que une réaction solaire
c'est à dire c'est quelque chose qui
vaporise tout sur son passage donc ça va
paporiser les arbres ça vaporise le
sable ça va borisent tout et donc c'est
un pacte tout la faune la flore et
d'ailleurs c'est assez rigolo c'est
quand on regarde quand on regarde les
analyses on se rend compte que les
militaires trouvent de la radioactivité
dans le poisson dans les plans de tombes
donc tout est détruit donc et ça on le
voit entre 66 et 74 à partir des années
de 1975 effectivement les essais sont
souterrains et là la question qui se
pose c'est effectivement les poissons
qui sont effectivement tués par ces
essais mais aussi la tôle même de mieux
voir puisque l'atoll de murora pourrait
expliquer schématiquement un essai
souterrain c'est un essai où on fait un
trou dans l'atoll ou au large et on tire
à plusieurs centaines de mètres de
profondeur et évidemment la question qui
se pose encore aujourd'hui c'est la
stabilité de cette atoll alors l'état
français a répondu à cette question mais
même de risques sismiques
risque sismique issu de l'effondrement
ce qui se passe c'est si ça s'effondre
ça provoque effectivement un séisme et
un tsunami et avec des projections très
pessimistes qui ont été revues à la
baisse encore aujourd'hui mais encore
une fois ça c'est une période et ça nous
renvoie cette question de
déclassification qui n'est pas concernée
par la dégling signification et nous
dans les documents qu'on a et qui ont
été déclassifiés très peu concernent
cette période des essais souterrains la
connaissance qu'on a majoritairement
elle est sur les essais atmosphériques
le reste est un peu plus
documentée très peu documentés
atmosphérique et ça c'est pas réparable
c'est les gars environnementaux
aujourd'hui ici il y a des mesures qui
sont prévues à cet effet alors il y a eu
des mesures de dépollution là pour le
coup on parle plus de on va dire la
machinerie des essais nucléaires si vous
voulez retirer certains bunkers à
certains endroits la décontamination il
y a des contaminations en revanche il y
a quelque chose dont on ne parle pas qui
est quand même assez important c'est je
suis sûr que Jean-Luc abusa pour un
témoigner parce que c'est des récits de
vétérans il y avait aussi ce qu'on
appelait l'océanisation l'océanisation
c'était jeter des déchets c'est à dire
des voitures des enghmans chantiers dans
l'eau et ça personne va aller les
chercher d'ailleurs c'est le terme
utilisé dans ce film mais comme vous le
dites il s'agit de jeter les déchets
irradés à la mer tout a été jeté dans le
avec les conséquences qu'on peut
imaginer bien évidemment pour la faune
marine et la flore marine sur cette
question des des dégâts environnementaux
on est assez loin de connaître la vérité
on l'a dit
et assez loin de d'imaginer quel con
préparation j'imagine oui je pense sur
ce sujet trois observations la première
encore en comparaison de penser aux
essais aux îles Marshall ou précisément
dans les îles Marshall il y a un dôme et
de la même manière qu'en Polynésie on se
pose le problème du risque
d'effondrement aux
îles Marshall en se pose la question de
la submersion du dôme et de ce que ça
produirait par rapport à d'autres
conversation ça nous pose aussi la
question de la valeur de l'attente parce
qu'au fond on a un temps qui est le
temps de la déclassification on a le
temps de l'instruction et on a de
l'autre côté le temps du risque sismique
ou du risque de soit de la disparition
de la donnée soit de l'amplification du
risque environnemental le mot de la fin
peut-être
au nom des victimes qu'est-ce qu'on peut
espérer pour elle des avancées à venir
attendu lesquels nous de toute façon on
souhaite une chose c'est que l'évolution
du fameux tableau des maladies parce que
on aimerait bien qu'il y ait quand même
certains cancers qui soient reconnus et
que dans son un peu victimes nos
vétérans comme le pharynx voilà ça c'est
des attentes importantes bon la
déclassification est très importante
parce que ça permettra sous les avancer
dans certains dossiers un petit peu
compliqués bien entendu et puis voilà
qu'il y ait une prise de conscience si
vous voulez que ces essais n'était pas
propre et on engendrer énormément de
maladies et puis tout tout ce qui se
rajoute à cela parce que bon les
victimes des essais nucléaires c'est une
chose mais maintenant il faut penser à
la descendance qui commence aussi à
avoir des suspicions de transmission ça
sera le mot de la fin merci vraiment à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat doc aujourd'hui consacré aux
essais nucléaires français en précisant
parce qu'on ne l'a pas dit dans notre
discussion que les essais sont désormais
réalisés par simulation et les essais
qu'ils soient souterrains ou
atmosphérique ont été arrêtés par
l'armée française en
1996 vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag
des Badoc sur Twitter à mon avis elles
ne vont pas manquer sur ce sujet merci
aussi à Selma Sally qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission et je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour une
prochaine émission des badox ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à bientôt
[Musique]